the father of flow so to speak is the
guy called Csikszentmihalyi
most people can't pronounce his name but
Kotler taught me therefore does the
Asian so check send me I wrote a book
called beyond boredom and anxiety and
typically human beings oscillate between
these states of boredom and or anxiety
or even like depression the point is
like we're anxious about the future or
melancholic for the past and and that's
like this constant FRIB relation
especially now it's acute this 21st
century normal like are so nervous will
feel so much pressure but there are
these moments in our lives where
everything aligns where things run
smoothly when we lose ourselves in an
experience when we lose track of time it
can happen you know the jazz musician
when he's in the pocket you know the
athlete when he's in the zone the writer
when it comes through him but not from
him and though it is with him it belongs
not to him I mean you feel there's an
artist at least like a conduit to
something larger than yourself and and
he's this particular experience this
state of consciousness that is defined
as flow is one in which you feel your
best and you perform your best and it
seems to emerge under all these
different conditions people have
different triggers there are different
contexts in which this particular flavor
of consciousness emerges and and
researchers and authors like Steven
Kotler and his organization the flow
Genome Project have pioneered some of
the research into this space they're
building on the work of csikszentmihalyi
and as it turns out when people are in
flow again not only do they feel their
best not only do they perform their best
but like existentially it puts them in
the right space because they're not so
concerned about the future anymore in
fact they're living in a deep state of
eternity now and one of the big bumper
stickers in the age of yoga and
meditation is learning to be more
present and I get that and I think like
for me to be in flow is to be present
because to be in flow shuts down the
part of the brain that measures the
passing of time so you literally are in
what Kotler calls the forever box
you know when the athlete is in the zone
when the surfer is riding that wave time
no longer exists right and you also lose
the inner chatter so one of the
hallmarks of flow is
at the inner Woody Allen the inner
critic which is parently controlled by
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex that
shuts down people think they use more of
their brain in a flow a actually you
lose less the aperture focuses as Jamie
wheel says and so the inner chatter
dissipates you have this quiet stillness
the sense of time disappears so you're
in eternity now right and then there's
this feeling of like information
richness and effortlessness that's also
transpiring so you don't feel the labor
of your actions you know your
performance level is through the roof
and the amount of information you have
access to is so smooth it's this
constant stream of new interpretable
information and there's actually a
neuroscientist who I listen to a podcast
on and he was saying that human beings
should be best described not as
carnivores or herbivores but as Infowars
because we're only ever truly happy when
we're eating new interpretable
information which is one of the
hallmarks of flow more access to more
information but notice he says
interpretable right it has to be the
sweet spot between chaos and order
because too much information if you're
flooded with too much data you become
overwhelmed wipeout you fall off the
wave if you're drowning underwater but
if you have too little information the
water is flat you're bored your mind
starts ruminating about the future of
the past but perfect flow is the perfect
wave and it toes the line between chaos
and order it's access to new
interpretable information and that's
where we are our happiness because we
are info wars damn I can't believe that
that entire nugget of knowledge just
screamed at me thanks for sure you bet
ask this question like a hundred times
yeah I think what is that just your
brain connecting in the way of Jason the
syllabus broken so I've done some
research I'm trying to explain what
happens to me when I get wrapped up in
explaining ideas and first of all what
I've learned is I'm an associational
thinker so I learned by association you
know and there's a line by a guy called
Isaiah Berlin called to understand is to
perceive patterns so connecting the dots
and associational thinking's for me at
least is how I wrap my head
around things and what typically happens
is and this is probably because for me
flow is again Tony the line between
chaos and order so flow is the
intersection between discipline and
surrender so like too much discipline is
oppressive and too much surrender is
chaotic when both are tensely balanced
you're in flow and so I would say that
for me these ideas you know they're
coming at me right and the discipline
part that urge to explain the urge to
language the urge to encapsulate is the
part of me that's a control freak is the
part of me that's highly disciplined
that wants to make order out of chaos
but the part that invites exposure to
new ideas that the part that avoids
dogma the part that is willing to
question everything I thought I knew the
part that invites disorder is me
bringing a little bit of cognitive
dissonance because that's where all the
new information comes in from and so
it's both you know I know a lot of
people that tell me Jason just let go
all that I just surrender you know but
if I just surrender I wouldn't have the
camera with me in the moment where the
ideas are coming through you know
obviously I'm getting out of my head for
all this inspiration to happen but I'm
also highly disciplined the cameras
charged the cameras there I've been I'm
with the right person and when the
download is happening it's like hit
record on that and I sense that you do
something very similar you know I've
noticed you in flow I've noticed the way
you run the conference but I also see
the machinations behind the scenes that
are so highly disciplined even the fact
that during this conversation you still
have the wherewithal to be like don't
forget about that camera so I think that
we're actually very similar